welcome back to glamour and filtered
house by meet Josh Smith and today we're
joined by model UNICEF ambassador
activist what do you not do oh you pay
me it's the one and only Halima Aydin
how are you today now you've just become
the face of bata top and together band
all at once as well and you are breaking
down boundary after boundary after
boundary like I was listing down your
achievements you're the first person to
wear hijab in the Miss Minnesota USA
pageant the first modest wear bikini on
the Sports Illustrated which went global
like what have you learned from breaking
down boundaries whoa oh my gosh I
learned so much in like the last three
years but Josh like never thought I
would ever like get to flip through a
magazine and see somebody who I could
like relate to wearing a hijab or
somebody who looked like me so I can't
even put into words how it feels to be
that person for like so many girls in my
community did you feel represented ever
growing up well there's nobody you know
there's not a hijab wearing model there
was not an actress there's not like
somebody who I could relate to in that
sense with the hijab and like you know
but I did have Hannah Montana but I
could relate to it does not look
anything like me you know it's she was
played by Miley Cyrus it was also like
the small-town girl like also having
this career in like music but also
coming back and going to school I don't
know why but I was like oh that's so
cool yeah but yeah I found little like
ways to relate to characters like Hannah
Montana but like never really somebody
who I could relate to on like a personal
level or you know something deeper than
that I guess you have to find your role
models in your everyday life as well I
guess yeah and then some people it's
like you don't have to look like me for
you to be a role model for me like I had
women like Oprah Winfrey who I looked up
to when I was younger and in school and
learning about everything like her life
journey what she's had to overcome to
become the woman that
she is and like just knowing that where
you come from doesn't define who you can
be tomorrow now you've had such like an
inspirational story like those of people
who don't know you would like born in a
refugee camp and then you came to the US
when you were seven yeah what was your
like first memory of that refugee camp
first of all I remember running around
almost butt-naked at times but let's be
honest like that was the best part about
growing up in a refugee camp is you got
your hands dirty you got your feet dirty
and it was like go out and play until
like the Sun Goes Down and then run back
run back home but it was definitely
challenging in terms of like not knowing
what your next meal is coming and like
malaria and like just the element and
like the fact that your entire future
your entire life livelihood is in limbo
at all times like that was devastating
and I think as like children like at six
I couldn't tell you what a refugee meant
or why I was that way because all I
remember was the camp I was born and
raised there it was home it was all I've
ever known so I had a great childhood
because I didn't know any better but it
was definitely a happy childhood in
terms of community I mean the refugee
camp it was like the largest I think it
still is the largest in Kenya you know
Kakuma is one of the biggest camps in
the world so it was refugees from all
over Africa and a lot of them were my
friends and so getting to alike learn
Swahili and speaking fluent Somali and
running around and singing like my
childhood was comprised of songs and
that was beautiful that's something that
I would never ever like change for the
world I wouldn't have had my life any
other way how do you think they seven
years of shape to you as a person it
made me rich in terms of I know what
brings me joy true joy is having friends
like having friendships even at six
seven like cultivating those
relationships it would have been so
boring if my camp was made out of just
other Somali boys and girls like I
couldn't tell you how like bland that
would have been probably right it's made
me rich
in terms of knowing what brings joy to
me to my heart you know and knowing that
you'll survive like I was fine in the
camp like we were thriving in other ways
right
so that that a resiliency of knowing
that no matter what life what curveball
life throws at me I know I'll be able to
tackle it I'm gonna be able to survive
it I'll know I'll get through it because
I've gotten through worse but I think
it's so amazing you can sit here and say
something that so many people who sees a
negative experience to say it's like
such an empowering experience well when
you have nothing but that you are forced
to see the beauty in the littlest things
the simplest things you are appreciative
you are grateful there is no such thing
as like a horrible horrible childhood
and then in a camp like I think there's
always a good side there is always a
bright side to any situation now you're
going to achieve all these incredible
things like being a pastor for UNICEF
like being the face of these incredible
brands do you feel like you're doing it
for that girl who was in that refugee
camp I see myself and I always think
like what would what would
twelve-year-old me what what message
could I have used you know that's why I
always tell girls don't change yourself
change the game and when I when I say
that I really mean be confident who you
are like where your identity with pride
no matter what that looks like no matter
what that is
we're probably and the right people will
accept you for you and you don't need to
fit the mold you don't need to fit the
mold you are just fine the way that you
are there were my campaigns and through
fashion and through this platform I keep
thinking like oh maybe I'm like telling
my younger self a message that I wish I
would have heard throughout your whole
life how is your relationship with your
hijab changed when I was younger I
definitely wasn't adventurous when it
comes to my hijab it was more about okay
I'm gonna just wrap my hair up and like
I didn't know much about fashion and
honestly I treated to clothes like I
just need something to cover my back
when I'm leaving the house fashion has
taught me so much in terms of how to
make my hijab customized to my
personality like this is an edgier look
this is younger I've gotten to
experiment soul in so many ways
well the last three years compared to
any any other time in my life
and it's just been incredible I just
want girls to know like just because you
wear the hijab doesn't mean like you're
not a young girl yourself like you still
should be able to experiment and make it
customized to your personality which is
such a great message to send out there
because so many people say so many
negative things and like actually you're
actually there saying this is actually a
symbol of my own voice it's what I grew
up seeing you know like my mom wore it
and then like I always looked up to her
and it's like lipstick if your mom wears
lipstick you kind of want to emulate her
beauty you kind of want to like if your
mom is walking around in heels like so
many little girls are like in boys I did
it there you go and I think thing for me
with the scarf I was like I wanted I
want to look like you I want to look
like her I'm definitely experimenting
when it comes to like ways to tie my
scarf ways to achieve turban looks
because girls are on my Instagram
telling me oh yes this this is good and
oh you really tried it and like oh you
know I mean like I love the feedback
that I get from other girls who wear the
hijab who maybe aren't in fashion and
maybe will never like get to experience
like working with a stylist but then
they can go to my Instagram page and
they can like make that same look and
they can find a community that
represents them as well which is such a
powerful thing about social media yeah
what a great thing you're doing is that
you're showing we're actually more
similar to people than we are actually
have differences from as well which is
such an important message to have and
that's what together band is all about
really it's about spreading messages of
togetherness how important do you think
that is for you sat here in like the
2020 world we're now living in I mean
look at us like we met today and and
before the camera started roaming like
we were able to just connect about
London and then I got to connect a
little bit of a Minnesota and like
Parent Trap and parents boom and it's
like yeah it's Lindsay Lohan all these
like things that just organically came
up lay down the barriers and just
connect with people and you see them for
exactly who they like it's togetherness
you know and so that's why I'm like so
excited to even with my collaborations
like it's not just fashion it's more
about what can we
do to combine both fashion and activism
what do you think being an activist
means to you I had a hard time using
that word to to describe myself and even
today like I don't really even save it
but for me I have a hard time because I
remember like the people who sacrifice
their entire life to come and volunteer
or to come teach in Kakuma they've done
so much in order to get that title so
sometimes I'm like have I really earned
that word and sometimes today I feel
like we throw it on so much but it's I'm
starting to be more appreciative and
like yeah I can be proud of myself like
yeah I'm doing something you know I'm
like using my platform and I always like
compare what I'm doing whatever it is to
like people who put in like the years
and like the sacrifice and you know what
I mean sometimes I'm like I'll give
myself a couple more years and like ask
me what do you think your careers taught
you about the power of your own voice
when you share your story when you wear
your heart on your sleeves when you're
it connects with people and it connects
with people in different ways like I've
gotten just as many messages from
Christian parents and girls who don't
look like me but maybe live in rural
Wisconsin or like small towns in America
who are like wait you didn't have to
move to New York in order to have a
career in fashion like that's so cool
like I didn't I didn't know that a girl
from a small town could go and do these
things and she relates to me in that
from that lens right and then I also
have the young some girls who are like
wow you're wearing a hijab and I I
wasn't maybe confident in it before but
I see you you know rocking it on the
cover of British Vogue and I'm like oh
I'll wear it proudly and like so many
different messages from different people
and so I think that's what happens when
you give your heart and soul and like
you're open like I've been very open and
honest about my journey and like the
good the bad the the happy the
everything sitting here today what do
you feel like is the most pressing issue
for you I look back at my years behind
the camp and that's you know that was
when I was seven I'm 22 now and I'm just
like how is it possible that today
we have more people in poverty than when
I was in the camp like to me that is
just devastating and then you look at
statistics like every two seconds a
person is displaced from their home due
to war due to famine due to poverty and
I have a very hard time digesting that
because I look at the world that I'm
surrounded by and there's so much wealth
there's so much glamour surrounding life
and that I'm just like what can we be
doing you know what can we be doing so
people don't have to live that way and I
think that's what's such an important
symbol of together band is that showing
that we should all see the similarities
we have in each other and that's the
goal 2030 that's the big you and gold
says 17 sustainable development goals so
hopefully 2030 will have zero zero
hunger zero poverty zero I mean those
are ambitious that's very ambitious but
I think that should be what every human
is like striving to to make happen let's
make it happen 2030 nothing's impossible
I mean and in honey you are a symbol of
much love that
[Music]